in this tutorial we're going to take a
look at how to incorporate 3d models
into any react application using react-3
fiber we're going to build a nearby
plane tracker so that you can see planes
that are near to you
wow we're going to do so using a 3d
model of the earth
and a 3d model of a plane hope you
enjoyed the tutorial and welcome to the
channel
[Music]
alright so welcome to the tutorial here
is the overview of what we're going to
go through today so let's look
uh overall on the project the package
that we're gonna use and the markup and
so on
create a story background convert some
models to jsx
render an earth a marker
some planes
fix the rotation and color of our planes
we're going to implement functionality
so it as you can click on the earth and
zoom in and out
we're going to rotate the earth to the
selected marker and then we're going to
add the location of the user
and then fetch some real planes from the
open sky api
and then calculate some cool information
for the plane that you're currently
watching
that should be it so let's start with
the overview so let's look at the
packages so
we have react spring for three which is
an animation library
we have reactory dry which is some
utilities
the core
renderer of 3d things
which is through f3 fiber and then we
have react-react-dom
react scripts for the bundling and web
server and so on since this is a create
react app start
and we have three
so let's look at the current markup that
we have we have a title
a canvas placeholder and some control
panel
so this is what it looks like
this big square is the
the reactory fiber canvas
it's not yet but it's going to be and
here down here we have the control panel
and here we just have a title that is
floating on top of the canvas
so inside of the control panel
all we have now is some information
about the current active marker that
we're watching we're going to come back
to this later
but the main state of the application is
a list of markers
and that is
a
combination of
you and more markers which are planes
so right now i just put one marker with
the id of me
and that has lat long zero zero
and we have another piece of state
that's called active marker id
and that is defaulted to me so as we can
see in the browser
the active marker right now is us
and so the control panel is showing
that we have
one marker type is person
and that long is zero
and the next and previous buttons are
disabled now because we only have one
marker so if we look here disabled if
marcus.length is one or less
so
i think that covers the overview
our first step is to create a star
background and in order to do so
we need to replace the canvas
placeholder which the actual canvas
and that canvas comes from
the react 3 fiber package
so let's render this canvas here
so we have a canvas to put 3d stuff into
we have some style that we need to put
on this canvas if we look at
this canvas placeholder
that has a height and a width that we
want to copy over to the real canvas
so this minus six pixels that was just
for the border the pink border that i
had so we don't need those
removed anymore because we don't want to
have a border
and the height will stay the same we
just subtract some space for the control
panel
so now we should have a real canvas in
the placeholder's place
and we also gonna put some stars on this
canvas too to very verify that it
actually works
so the stars
we're going to
get from dry
and it's very simple we just import it
and we render the stars
component so now we should actually see
something here
now we have a real 3d canvas and we have
some stars that are twinkling
so that covers another step in our
tutorial
so let's check that one
so now it says convert gltf models to
jsx and in this tutorial we're going to
use two different models one is of the
earth and the other one is of a plane
so we need to go download these
and here we have the airplane model
and the other model is
linked here in the readme which is the
earth model so let's open up the earth
model as well
so let's start with the earth model it
looks like this
it's created by patel dev and
when you use it we need to
give attribution to the creator
so that attribution is in the readme
so the format that we want to download
here is gldf we download that
and we see that we get some files here
and this is what they look like and i am
going to take them and put it in the
public folder of our code repo
so as we can see these files are called
scene and since we are going to be
downloading two they're going to
conflict so we need we need to remain
rename scene to earth
but one thing to be aware of is that the
scene
dot bin is referenced here so we need to
rename this reference as well
so we'll rename it to earth.bin
like that
and save it
and now we can safely rename these two
so
earth.gltf and earth.bin
great we also have a textures folder
that we got with the earth and if we
open this jpeg here we can see that this
is the texture that is going to wrap the
sphere that is the earth
so before we can use this inside of
react we need to use a converter
so
and there's a package for that
so if i step into the public directory
and i reach for the package gltf jsx
and then i point it to earth.gltf
it will do it will create a component
for us
so now we have earth.js here that we can
place in our components folder
so let's import earth into the app
but let's see what we have inside earth
so we have some
some info about the model
we have a group a rotation
and i think we should be able to just
take this and render it
so we place it inside the canvas
but there is one thing missing before we
can see this earth
and that is a light because if you are
observant you can see in the middle here
it's just a black hole
and the earth is not a black hole
so we need to add a light
inside here
so we'll add
a point light
and
let's place it
10 5
10
there we go so now the earth is
illuminated
it sort of looks like the sun is shining
on it
but the earth is a bit small in my
opinion
so what we can do
let's first just clean up a few things
that we're not going to use here
and these props will remove
so to the outermost group here let's add
a scale
so let's add scale 2 and we just doubled
it in size
i also see that there are two
inner groups here
where one is doing
a rotation on the x-axis for minus math
dot pi divided by two
and the next group
does the exact opposite
so these two group should should just
cancel out
so if i try to remove those two groups
to clean it up a bit
we should see that we have the exact
same because they were just cancelling
each other out
all right
um so we have a working earth model
let's do the plane model while we're at
it as well
so we have this airplane created by omar
muhammad attribution to you also in the
readme
so we download it just the exact same
process it will be called scene again
like this and i will take the file and
place them
inside the public folder
so same process again
see if it references scene.pin and it
does
and we'll call it plane
dot pin
and then rename it plane dot pin
and
plane dot gltf
all right
so now it's time to do the conversion
plane
done
and let's move it into components
so this one i will render next to the
earth here
plane from
plane
and we wrap this in a fragment
and render the plane here
let's have a look so
if we look inside the plane component
let's clean up a few things that we're
not going to use
there we
go so you always need to look through
what's been generated here so something
that sticks out to me here is that the
cylinder position is
moved upwards by 300
and that's the y-axis so it might be
that this plane is
really high up and i think it was
so now it's centered but it is really
really huge so let's change the scale of
this plane
so let's do 0.1
and it became smaller but it's still
huge
so let's take it down another factor 10.
and it's still pretty huge
let's
rotate it
and i always have to guess which axis to
rotate it
so if we
start with zero zero zero let's try for
the x axis
and this is in radians so we do math dot
pi and since two pi is a full rotation
half a pi is half a rotation or one pi
is a half rotation
so
so two pi is one rotation
one pi is a half rotation so half a pipe
would be 90 degrees
so let's try to rotate it 90 degrees
rotation
all right so that's good it looks like
we got a top view there
so let's also change the position of it
so we want the plane to come towards us
which means this said axis
so we'll do zero zero
and
let's try two
so it came towards us
the scale is still crazy so if i look
here i can see that
the scale is a hundred here so let's try
changing that to one instead of a
hundred
and let's try moving it closer to us
because now it might be inside of the
earth
there we have it
so it's starting to look decent here
uh the next thing
what's the next thing that we're going
to do so we took our models and they
have been converted to jsx so that step
is done
we have
we have done the earth
we have done the planes
we're also going to create a marker that
is not a plane
so by a marker that is not the plane
what i mean is if we want to show the
user location we don't want to show it
with the plane because that would just
be confusing
so i will show you one way of doing that
so
on the earth component here let's render
out
a mesh
and inside the mesh we're both going to
put a geometry and the material
so we're going to put a sphere geometry
sphere
geometry
and we're going to put a mesh
mesh
standard material
so for this material we can pick a color
and i am going to pick orange
and for the geometry we can specify a
size with the args prop
so here we can set the radius and let's
set 0.1
and with this mesh we can set the
position
and i do know from the plane
that we need to
increase the set a bit in order for it
to not end up in the middle of the earth
so i think i used
maybe four or something
so let's see if we can get this mesh to
appear and there we have
our sphere geometry
with the orange color
so i think this for a marker it's still
really really big
so now it's placed inside of the plane
so now we have our components we have
the earth we have a plane
and we have a marker
so now we are done with these three
so the next thing that we're going to
work with is the rotation and color of
the plane
so we're not
yet fetching planes from the api
so i think we should create a fake plane
in the markers list
so let's make up an id for it
it will in from the api it will be like
hex hex strings
so we could say aa01be
that could be a valid id
and that
let's just make it
five
and loan five so it's not in the same
place
and type
let's add type now so type explain
and
type is
human
all right so now we have two markers
and so then we could also actually try
out the control panel
so we see that we have two markers the
first one is a human
and the second one is a plane
and the logic for that is just this type
here if active marker type is plane the
plane emoji or otherwise the human
and we will display the lat long and
just the
marker index
so we already fixed the rotation of the
plane
and the other rotation
we're going to need to do once we start
to get data
about the plane because then we can
figure out what direction the plane is
heading
so then we can calculate what the
rotation is
but we can fix the color of the plane
right now
each unique plane should get a unique
random color
and that should be based on the id that
the plane has
so what we're going to do is that we're
going to
go into the materials from the model
and i know that the body of the plane
is called
material
zero zero one
that has a color object
so we can modify this color object
and this color object has three props it
has r g and b
so let's start with the r
so we have this id
and if we take
the first two
letters in this id
we can
since it's two hex values
if we do parseint with base 16 we will
get a random number between
0 and 2 5 6.
so i'll do parse in
and base 16
and this
material color should each r g and b
should get a number between 0 and 1.
so i need to divide it by two five six
and and then we will land somewhere
between zero and one
since the parse end
of these two hex values
will be somewhere between zero and two
five six so i'll just
duplicate it
for g and b
and let's look at different slices of
this id
for the different colors
so i think this is a nice deterministic
way of getting a random color
for each plane
that it will keep
all right but right now we're not
passing in an id to a plane
so let's just
try something
so we have the plane here and we say
that id is equal to
we can take this one that we made up
and now is
the the plane used to be green
but
this id
ended up making the plane pink
so that is going to work well for us
once we get real planes with real
ids
all right so moving on in the list
we'll call this one done for now the
next item is to zoom the earth when we
click it
so we need to keep track of if the if
the earth is zoomed in or not we can
also rename this from model
to earth
to be more clear we can also do that
with plane
so let's import the u-state hook
so luke const
is zoom
set is
zoom
we'll default that to false
and
let's add an on click
to this outermost group here
so all we need to do is call set assume
take the previous value and return the
opposite of that
so now we should have
piece zoom
so every time i click the the earth now
we should toggle this back and forth
true false true false
that's great
and so we want to animate the scale of
the earth
depending on the assumed value
so what we need to bring in
is the use spring hook
so we will import you spring and this a
and i think the a stands for animate and
it's something that you can put
in front of the tags that you plan to
animate it means that you spring will
will take control of it
so we'll
we will call the use spring hook and
give it an object
i will set a scale prop here
and
right now we have scale 2
so we'll say that if if is zoom
then do scale four otherwise do scale
two
so we need to the structure scale here
from the
from what the spring is returning
and replace
the scale here with the spring scale
so now let's try it and see if we can
click the earth and zoom in
so now we have the zoom in functionality
and as we can see
we need to also move our marker and
plane according to the zoom
so
what we can do
is that we can set a marker
position inside the spring as well
so if it's assumed we want to move it
closer to us
otherwise we keep the default value that
we have now
and what we have is four
so we can do zero zero five maybe if it
is zoomed in
and let's destructure out marker
position
and we'll add that
to our
marker here so instead of this we say
marker
position
so let's see if it works for the marker
uh we we need to add the a dot to this
mesh for it to work
all right so we see that it is in fact
working but we're moving this sphere
geometry a little bit too much
so let's see if we can have this as like
4.5
i think we can probably lower this a bit
yeah so it's hard to see if it works now
when the plane is in the way so but
we're gonna do it for the plane
too
so we'll say position prop
and we'll pass in the marker position
we need to import
just
this a
for now
so that we can
receive the position
and use it here
and add the a to this group
so now we put the same animation on the
plane
so let's see what happens yeah so they
animate together and they seem to
to follow the earth pretty good
i would probably like to just take them
down
a tiny bit more
so let's try
2.5 here and see if they are still
above the surface of the earth yes
that felt a little bit better
so then we are done with the zoom earth
on click
so now we move on to the rotation of the
earth
so
what we want to do is that
the earth should receive a marker
and adjust its rotation to the long left
of that marker
so we'll
that we pass a prop called marker and we
pass in the active marker
so right now we set the active marker to
me
and me has zero zero
so we need to figure out where is long
lat zero zero
left one zero zero
and that's on a place called nol island
and if we google for some pictures we
can see that it is outside of the coast
of africa
and we can have these two points as as
reference points
so it should be a tiny bit about this
point a tiny bit to the right from this
point
so
let's receive this marker
and we can
we can take out
the lat long from
this marker
and let's add
the rotation to the spring so it
animates nicely
so this is something that we need to
calculate now and
the hard part is that
lat long is essentially degrees
and what we need to pass
to react 3 fiber is in radians
so we need to do a conversion here
so we'll say let
rotation is equal to
lat times
math dot pi
divided by 180
and for the long
we need to do
is flip it
and what i do know because i've used
this earth model before is that
it is offset by 90 degrees
so let's store that in
a constant here long
offset
is
so 90 degrees
would be
[Music]
math of pi divided by 2.
so let's use this
in here
and zero for the set axis
and let's the structure
the rotation
and let's put the rotation on this group
here
rotation is
rotation
so if things went correctly we should
see
the null island being
under the marker and the planes
and if we look at this point here it
looks quite correct and i think from
this point also it's also quite correct
so i think we are on track
so let's
try
with this plane
and the other plane that we have we can
take a known coordinate and see if the
earth rotates
to that coordinate so let's stay
long lat new york
so we have 40.7
and for the long we have minus 73
so now we should be able to switch using
the control panel
yes and we moved to new york in fact
so great we can switch between null
island and new york
pretty cool
so does that take another item in our
list rotate earth to selected marker yes
we can do that
so our next step is to geolocate the
user
so i have this
hook here
that i stole from another project
so it's called use geolocation and you
just call it and you get a location back
or first you get null back
and then you wait for the navigator
geolocation
to get the current position and then
once it has it it will no longer be null
it will be
we should name this
loan
it will say usually you locate it and
print it out and then set that location
and if this doesn't work it will say
this site needs your location to fetch
planes around you
so let's call this
hook
from the app here
user location is
use
geolocation
so
this will be null first and then it will
be a relocation so when we declare these
markers
let's check if user location is done
if it is
we can
spread this in here
user location
and if we don't have it
then we can just keep this sample plane
and
let's default to the plane instead
of the user
so now we see that one marker
and then we have two markers
and that it changed because we are
placing
the hue the human before the plane so
once it finds it the plane is no longer
at index one is at index two
but now
let's see if i switch to the me marker
if it jumps to where i am in the world
and it does
so this is where i am
so what we know want to fix now since we
have a person and the plane we can fix
so that we render the plane for the
plane and the marker for the person
so we can fix that inside of the earth
component
because we receive a marker here that
has a type
so
if marker.type
is equal to plane
we want to render
the plane
otherwise
we want to render the marker
so let's see okay so now i'm on a person
so we should render the orange
dot marker
and when i switch to plane it changes to
the
plane but i think now
it could be time to start looking at
some
real data from the api
so here is what the api
looks like so
you call state slash all you get
an array of planes
and each plane is also represented by an
array where the index means different
things so zero is
an id and then we have origin country
long let is important
and then we have category and so on
so we will save a few of these
attributes
and i took the liberty of saving
two
requests
and they are separated in time by like a
minute
so before we do the real request we
could actually use these two sample
requests
but let's use the sample data inside of
this use planes hook that i plan to use
for fetching planes
and but one thing that we need to fix is
that
if we
since we have two samples
we want to the first time we fetch we
want to fetch
this first sample and the second time we
fetch we want to fetch
the second sample
so let's add a piece of state to keep
track of our fetch count
so we have use date and we'll start at
zero
let's declare a function
called
fetch
planes
and we'll wrap that in a use
callback
so if
fetch count is smaller equal to two
or i mean
larger equal to
two that means that we fetch twice and
then we don't have more sample data so
we just want to return
otherwise we can
set these planes
to the next sample data
set planes
so we do
set
planes
sample planes
fetch count
so we'll destroy this
so we initialize to an empty array
and then we're going to call fetch
planes and we'll get the first sample
and then we need to update the fetch
count
so prev
one
and then the second time it will do the
next sample and then we're out of
samples
fetch count
so we need to
we need to handle a few things here
because
it might be
that
some planes are new some get removed and
some should just be updated
so we should fix that
when we're going to fetch these planes
but first we should map over these
sample planes because this is raw data
in the shape that the api delivers it
so we don't want to keep all of this and
we want instead of an array we should
use an object
so it's easier to work with
so we'll do a mapping of all these
planes
so we can dig out some properties from
plane here
we saw from the api that the first thing
in the array was the id
and then the origin country is
interesting
so we skip one and we take the origin
and then how many do we want to skip
one two
we skip two places and we go for the
longitude
skip skip and then we take the long
and then we'll take the lat
and i think that's all we
want and then we return
an object
so we take all of these
and of course this is going to be a
plane so we add type
plane
and we're also going to handle
once we have seen more than one
coordinate of a plane
we want to figure out how do we rotate
this plane so that it aligns with where
it's going
so if the previous coordinate was
straight south from it we want to have
the plane face north because then it
came from the south and the direction
should be north and we want to rotate it
accordingly
but if this is the first time we're
reading this plane
then we don't know about the rotation
so we'll set it to zero for now
so now we have an array of all the
fetched planes but they are
structured in an object instead of an
array
so we can filter out which planes of
these fetch planes were new
so the new planes would be
[Music]
we can do this inside
a set planes call
where we get
the current planes
which is the previous date
so we can compare the fetch planes to
the current planes
and filter out just those that are new
so we can take the
fetchplanes.filter
and for each
fetch plane
we check if
current planes if some of them
[Music]
if some id in there
is equal
to
the fp.id
and
we should check that they are not there
if they are not if that id is not seen
in the current planes it means that it
is a new plane
so now we have a list of all the planes
that are new
and those we just want to add to our
state
but we also need to check for all the
all the planes that already existed in
our state
because those are the ones that we can
calculate the rotation for
check for existing planes in
state and calc
rotation
const
existing
planes
so here we can do something very similar
here
so essentially we do the same thing
but we check for those that did exist in
the current planes
and so on these we want to do a map and
all
the only thing we're going to change in
this mapping is that we calculate the
rotation
so this is our fetched planes which
means that this is the latest lat and
loan
so we also need to know the previous
value of last and long
so that we can do
like this
current plane
so we look in the current planes and we
find
this plane dot id
and from that we can structure out lat
as prevlat and
as
prev
long
and
rotation as prev rotation
current lane
so now we have everything we need to
figure out how to rotate this plane
and
rotation is equal to
we also need to verify that
either the lat or loan changed because
if we have the exact same coordinates
again
we have the exact previous coordinates
as we have the incoming coordinates then
we still cannot calculate rotation
because the plane has
stood still in the data
so we make sure that
lat is not equal to prevlat
or
loan is not equal to prevalent
if that is the case
then we can calculate the rotation
but
if they were the same then we just have
to keep the previous rotation
so this calc rotation function is a
function these two functions both
calculating the distance between left
and long pairs and calculate the
rotation
of two lat lone pairs or functions that
i have not written myself but they seem
to work great
so here we pass in
last one
long one lat two long two
long
priv last
priv long
so we need to import that function as
well
calc rotation
all right so
we also need to return from this map
and that will still be an object
where we spread the plane
and we set the rotation
so now
we can say that our new state for the
planes
is
the new planes
and then
the existing planes
so let's make a little log for ourselves
here so that we see what's going on
so we can say that
existing planes dot length
updated
and new planes
dot length
added
so now we can see how many planes
existed but we just calculated the
rotations or updated them
and how many were added
so now all we have to do is return this
new state from the set planes function
but i also would like
to
sort them based on the distance
so in order to figure out the distance
we need to
utilize
the user location inside here
so if we have the user location we can
say that distance
is equal to
calculate this
calculate
distance
[Music]
and then we can take the location which
which will be the user location
so we just need to make sure that we
pass in the user location
to this hook
and import the calc distance function
so now we can store
the distance to the user for every plane
and when we have that we can take our
new state
and sort it
so we return a dot distance minus b dot
distance
all right
so i think
we have a working plane hook here
here it should be fetched
this variable is called fetched planes
so here it should be fetched planes and
here it should also be fetched planes
all right so let's use this hook inside
of the app component
const
planes is use
planes and we need to pass in the user
location
so we also need to handle in the use
planes if
the user location is not found
so we could say
we pass in the user location
or we pass in
lat zero
long zero
so it will never break
so now instead of this sample plane
we could spread in planes
so this needs to change now
so i see what happens here
if we don't have an active marker id
then active marker will be
undefined or null
so we'll pass that in here
so what we could do is that we could
just pass in
if we don't have the active marker yet
we could just pass in
the null island
and then we could actually set this to
me
so now we'll wait for the user to be
geolocated
and then we start
okay so we're not receiving any planes
yet because we're not calling this fetch
plane so let's do that in a use effect
here
fetch planes
so let's see now
we got
50 planes
so we have some console logs here
we see that zero place updated but 49
were added
so we run the fetch planes
once
i think if we were to add
location here
we might run it actually twice
so now we see
zero updated 49 added zero updated 48
added
so let's make sure we have all our
dependencies correct
so this one uses
fetch count
fetch
count
and
set fetch count
and set planes
and it also uses location
this one should have fetch planes
all right oops here we have another set
planes that shouldn't really not be
there
alright let's see what happens
so now it looks more correct so the
first sample we have 49 planes added
and then on the second sample
we have 48 updated
so we saw that one plane must have flown
out of bounds
so we
some plane left the the
bounds
in which we request planes from
so that looks good
so now we can see
we have a lot of planes here
so
let's add the distance to the control
panel
so we can say that
if
marker.type is plane
then we know that we have for example
the distance and the origin and so on
we can do
distance
in kilometers
and this needs a fragment
and this should be active marker
and we can also add
origin
so if we switch to a plane now we get
the distance
and
it's a plane that came from poland
and it's six hundred
six thousand two hundred and twenty one
kilometers away
wow
and we'll set this in a div
there we go
so the final step is to implement the
rotation that we calculated so that the
plane is facing the correct direction
so we can
pass in the rotation here
because we have that
in earth
rotation
marker dot
rotation
exists
so we receive rotation and that should
of course be animated
so now let's import use spring
call it rotation
so this is what we're starting with
so i suspect that we need to put the
rotation
on the y-axis here
let's call these ones plane rotation
so now we can replace this value
with plane
rotation
so let's see what happens okay change
direction at least
and it says it came from the netherlands
so that could be correct
this one came from denmark
this one came from norway
came from sweden
from ukraine
yeah i think it's probably correct so
now we have the rotation but one thing
that is not so nice is that it looks
like it's always
the same plane
so one way to fix that is to play with
the scale of the plane
so we could do
a spring here
from scale
0
to scale 1
and let's add a config
of
duration
500.
so we have the scale and we want to
trigger this whenever the id changes
so we can
put a use effect here
so whenever the id
changes
we want to do scale.reset
so let's see if that worked
and it was not two
to one it was 0.01
and we need to remove the old scale here
so let's see what happens now
so it seems like there is something
wrong with the id because i also see
that
material is not changing so let's look
inside of the earth
oh we hardcoded the id here
so we'll do marker dot id
so now we also get some new colors
and whenever we change the plane
it sort of appears from the ground
so now it looks a lot better
so let's look through our tutorial to-do
list
the only thing we have
left
is to change this to actually fetch real
planes
and we already prepared for this so
it won't be too hard for us
so instead of getting the planes
from here we just need to to fetch the
planes
so we can remove these
fetch count things
and we want to do this mapping on the
real data instead
we just need to get the data first
so we can do the fetch
and let's
get the url
so here we have the base url
and we need
also to to say within what
long left boundaries do we want to get
planes
so we do the base url
and then we do a query parameter
we do la min
is equal to
[Music]
lat minus bound
size
and then we just continue this pattern
for l o mean
equal to
loan minus bound size
and for the
l a
max and lo max we just add the bound
size
so this returns a promise
and in that we get response
and that
response we read the json response
and that returns
a promise
and in there we get the data
so now we need to wrap our whole
function in this fetch
so let's refresh
and now we have wow this is live data
coming in
the final step would be
to have this run
on an interval
so that we can figure out
the rotation of them because now
they're all facing just south
so we need to get two requests in before
we can calculate the rotation
so let's use the use interval hook here
use
interval
and that will be
just the same as this and we tell it to
run every 10
seconds
so this is a hook that just takes a
callback and a delay and it will execute
the function on that
delay on every interval
here we should have ten thousand
so our first planes are in
and now they got their
direction
so pretty cool
so that's all i wanted to show you today
thank you so much those of you that
reached this far it got a bit
complicated in the end with the
calculation of the distances and
rotations and
i hope you learned a thing or two about
creating 3d things within the browser
i think react 3 fiber is a great library
for those that know react it makes it a
lot simpler
to have everything in a component
hierarchy like like within react
so i'd be really happy if you want to
pay my channel a visit if you're looking
for more educational content around
javascript typescript web development
stuff like that
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you again in the future
[Music]
[Music]
you